ich weiß nicht warum aber ganz viele
leute haben sich teil 2 gewünscht von
daher herzlich willkommen
zwei finger was willst du denn jetzt
hier stört mich gerade beim video machen
ich mag hat einen chip muss alles wegen
diesen vorne anfangen
schauspielerische leistung ist wieder
brutal raster sogar sandra diesmal
mitgespielt hat irgendwie ein
bilderrahmen kaputt gemacht habe und ich
habe auch mit ron darüber gesprochen und
ich an dich so
dann gehe auch weg und lass die
seraphina ihr blut hier dinge wirklich
so leicht kann ich das schlecht an wenn
ich hab ich dir verzeihen kann der blick
sagt dort werde ich auch alles ich tue
auch alles was was kann ich machen was
du mir zeigst du kannst du meine nägel
lackieren
[Musik]
ja
völlig normale freundschaftliche
beziehungen da bin ich das machen wir
dann wieder beste freundin und
streitpunkt nicht mehr
ja das überlege ich mir noch was ist
diese seraphina für ein monster
da bin ich wieder jetzt geht die gt wird
hier weiter so erklärt ja das super wie
du das hier dann auch films eigentlich
ist es plot vista baby palace vor zehn
jahren
dafür habe ich natürlich meine dina
meine angestellten warten ob du fühlst
weiter ja natürlich allerdings tut er
nicht was denkst du denn durchgehend
online durch
beim abschuss ich mach mir da nicht
selber meine fußnägel #bpw #bv10 von der
letzten folge weiter übrigens meine bank
immer noch wie ich schon mal ich kann
weiter machen aber dann machen wir nicht
ins die kamera aus ja ja gut so
das ja eigentlich ein kleines pimpf
stativ also seraphina bevor du da mit
deinen nägeln und einen hahn
weitermachen würde ich erst mal ein
richtiges stativ holen also mainz hat 25
euro gekostet das hashtag döner macht
schöner video dass sowas von durch die
decke gegangen
das hat sie so viele aufrufe so und
niemand hat an safina geglaubt außer ich
wenn ich jetzt mit 180 anteil danke
gestört werden worin heftig vermisst
in acht bildern beauty weiß gott was
tutorial so was irgendwie passt das auch
gar nicht so alles drüber msi das denn
dahin fünf foto alters ich mich so ein
bisschen frage bei serafin das
lebensstil ist auf der einen seite will
wieso komplett beauty mäßig machen und
macht massen auf der anderen seite
frisst sie dann dünner
ich mache mir gedanken über das leben
einer geschauspielert eine rolle
ich bin so los sei influenza wie ich ich
muss einfach alles können so musste aber
verstehen ja aber davon ab sich eine
ahnung so nämlich das ja gar keine
ahnung von safina lasse ich nicht
runterziehen von diesem unwissen merkt
man deutlich dass seraphina in ihrer
eigenen welt lebt und versucht in diesem
ganz speziellen slang zu reden
dabei weiß sie nicht unbedingt immer
ganz genau wovon sie sprechen hashtag
allwissend mal davon gehört wird boom
ist der wahre boss hat so wenig leicht
bekommen ich überhaupt nicht verstehen
dass er so gut aus das foto ja
corona klimaerwärmung also das sind
alles themen die einfach wirklich
zweitrangig zu behandeln sind
der letzte post von sarafina hat weniger
likes als sonst hallo merkel putin trump
könnt ihr hier einschreiten seraphina
was dann hast du dir nagellack nicht
gefunden ist das ein scheiß ernst war
die mannschaft sehen ja die sind schön
aus richtig perfekt
[Musik]
hat seraphina ihren eigenen namen auf
die schuhe ihrer schwester geschrieben
und hat sich vor allem ihre maske gerade
mit einem score joghurt gemacht
als nächstes kann es ja da noch eine
tomatensuppe und stracciatella joghurt
auf klatschen
das ist mein erster eigener fertig ist
wird so durch die decke geht alle werden
den schul lieben gott ist das dein ernst
hashtag safina high heels ja
mittlerweile verstehe ich die kommentare
von wegen die sagt viel zu selten
hashtag ich habe keine gefunden bei mir
nein so schön aus ist der rafina das
neue schuhe weiß sowie waren so viele
leute gern den schuh kaufen dann bin ich
einfach hashtag fans dass das wichtigste
joghurt in der presse und hashtag famous
dann bekommst du das ganze geht schon
wieder wenn nicht mehr rot rosa fina hat
hier ganz klar eine sachbeschädigung
begangen sie hatten
das ist kunst für rafina sieht das
naturgemäß ganz anders sie ist die ganze
aktion eine verschönerung und somit eine
wertsteigerung
ist es auch
die macht jetzt merge und ist dann zudem
ist sie
wie entstehen eigentlich popel
ich ersetze die weil du weißt doch
hashtag rich and famous bald bin ich in
grenzen
sonst seraphina ersetzt ihrer freundin
da anscheinend ich dachte dass wir die
schwester ist man schon die freundin
aber sie ersetzt die schuhe hashtag rich
and famous alles gut war um den streit
mit serie beweist actionfans weil wir
nicht in grenzen da kann ich hier 1000
verkaufen so wenn ich sogar 1230 paar
kurz darauf seraphina ist nur eines
wichtig ihre follower zu beeindrucken
ja
da bin ich mal gespannt was die jetzt
macht vielleicht irgendwie ein food
tutorial oder irgendwie so zwar nicht
einfach aber ich habe jetzt eine reinere
freunde
[Musik]
raffinerien tort der sinn von hashtags
ist es gewiss keine chicken nuggets
verbringen
aber das muss doch irgendwie besser
leben ja
vielleicht wenn du nicht die frontkamera
an macht sondern die andere kamera
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich will damit nicht nur influenza auch
professionelle fotografen verwenden
bildbearbeitungsprogrammen selbst fotos
von supermodels werden retuschiert
alles natürlich bei mir hab ich
fragt mich ob da jetzt noch irgendwas
was ist denn jetzt ihre idee also steigt
der mittlerweile wirklich überhaupt ich
mir durchaus steck safina ist so schlau
was das macht sie denn jetzt richtige
schlacht werden
was machst du denn hier vielleicht
sollte ich nicht pausieren da die
version zeigen
[Musik]
ne
ihre freundin beim duschen oder was
ich kann mir das nicht weiter gucken
also das ist wirklich eine der mit
abstand schlimmste hilfen erfolgen die
ich je gesehen habe wenn euch mal die
reaktion dennoch gefallen liebe freunde
das geld einen daumen hoch und wieder
her da abonniert main kanal fällt in
einen dritten teil hier drauf nicht
verpassen wollte sofern er denn
passieren wird
[Musik]